all right here's a question yeah I'm
writing you from Kabul Afghanistan and
my question is we know the speed of
light do we know the speed of dark and
what is dark
oh okay so philosophers I'm Batman yep
philosophers like asking questions such
as that yeah problem is if you line the
verbs and now so that it makes something
that sounds like a clayey doesn't mean
that it's an actual legitimate way it's
like saying what flavor cheese is the
moon made of right that's a quite as a
quick as well just a lid this illiterate
watch out you're gonna spark a war in
Afghanistan
so what is the speed of dark if dark is
the absence of light dark has no speed
so there's an answer at zero well of the
moon is not brief so so so just because
we have a word for something that is the
absence of light doesn't mean the
absence of light is a thing rather than
ask questions about right physically
right like I said philosophers go you
know what is the sound of one hand
clapping you know where the bells if
it's doing a well it's still like this
you can hear it but I just literally one
hand clapping what hand back wrapping
itself yeah yeah so then that's there
that's the back door answer to that so
so dark has no speed because it in fact
does not exist as an entity what we call
dark is the absence of live